[Music]
i've been following the story of the
rice brothers for about 10 years now
since soon after they started their
company rice energy they're based in
pittsburgh pennsylvania and focused on
drilling and fracking an area called the
marcellus shale this is the nation's
biggest natural gas field that produces
roughly a third of all united states gas
right now
we grew up in the outskirts of boston my
father was in the financial part of the
oil industry he gave us the rundown of
the industry and it sounded interesting
to us and he said maybe you guys should
start a company one day we decided right
there that's what we wanted to do
we had no direct experience drilling
wells everything that we knew about
drilling oil and gas wells we learned in
a classroom
but we hit the ground and we were thrown
into the deep end and had to try to
figure it out on the fly
they were new to fracking they didn't
have any experience and the whole
industry didn't even have any
infrastructure in that area around
pittsburgh so i was interested in them
because they were really starting from
scratch
at a new time for the industry
my first job in this industry was a
forehand on a work over rig which is
sort of bottom of the totem pole was
making nine dollars an hour with a two
dollar an hour bonus for safety
that gave me a tremendous appreciation
for the the men and women that are in
the field working in all conditions
and was was a very tremendous experience
for me to understand you know for you to
be successful in this business you have
to have great people in the field
so it's kind of wild to think that these
three brothers just woke up and decided
yeah we're going to start an oil company
but that's kind of what they did their
father was very involved in oil and gas
investing and so that he knew
that there was something special that
had been discovered in the marcellus
shale area of pennsylvania so he knew
that if they were early enough into this
new field they might be able to lock up
enough drillable acreage that's what
everyone was fighting over 10 years ago
in order to get control of enough acres
to where you can drill these really long
wells
they call themselves the shale ennials
so these were the young environmentally
minded generation that was going to take
over the natural gas fracking business
they went public in 2014
and then in 2017 the rice brothers sold
their company to pittsburgh-based eqt
eqt is the nation's biggest producer of
natural gas
and when they added rice energy to their
combination they got even bigger so they
went from starting their own company
building their own company selling their
company
then being totally unhappy about who
they sold it to
to such an extent that they decided to
fight to get it back again and so now
toby rice is the ceo of eqt and his
brother danny is on the board and derek
is also a consultant
so they are leading
now the biggest
company in the u.s natural gas industry
and they're barely 40 years old so this
is really the generation that is going
to be leading the industry over over the
next 20 years
[Music]
when we first started out 10 years ago
that was the hot topic was is fracking
dangerous typically the issues that
happen in the field like whether it's
fracking or drilling a well
the most common occurrence of those
issues is people not following
procedures or mechanical failures but
the actual act of
doing the process itself as designed
the success rate is
99.999
we knew the magnifying glass was on us
every single day landowners regulators
and so we always wanted to be
transparent with them and always knew
that you know if we did have any issues
whatsoever they would come to light and
look i think the industry welcomes that
more now than ever
through eqt we are going to be
eliminating all of our pneumatic devices
we're going to be cutting our methane
emissions by over 65
this is going to a big part of us
reaching our net zero goals by 2025
methane emissions is something that this
industry will
address the concerns that the public has
about climate change certainly makes
being an energy executive a very
challenging time but this is also i
think one of the most exciting times to
be in energy since the rice brothers
sold their company they've been working
on reinvesting the roughly 250 million
dollars that they made they have
sponsored two special purpose
acquisition companies the most
successful of those so far is called
archaea energy what makes archaea energy
so interesting is that they capture the
natural gas
that
wafts out of landfills unless you have
systems to collect that methane that's
just naturally leaking off of the
landfills that methane goes into the
atmosphere which is very harmful there's
this company archaea that we backed and
we spaced
and they go out and collect that methane
and just to put into perspective the
potential impact from collecting that
gas
if archaea collected the gas from all 3
000 landfills in the united states
the emission reduction would be
equivalent to electrifying 75 of the
vehicle fleet in the united states and
so when we think about how to solve some
of these problems
we ask ourselves the question would we
rather electrify 250 million vehicles
which is going to be a monumental effort
or would we rather collect the gas from
2500 landfills
and it's those types of ideas that we're
going to pursue is because we know pound
for pound when we deploy those dollars
it's gonna have a bigger impact than
anything we can invest in the public
market i'm always fascinated to learn
about these stories of entrepreneurs who
create something from nothing what was
different about the rice brothers is
that they
had a lot of help from their father they
got tens of millions of dollars to start
this company but you can't just start a
drilling company in a garage you need a
lot of capital you need a lot of
investment
and then you need to go out and hire
massive amounts of expertise so it was
just amazing to me that
these young guys took on all of that
challenge all of that risk
when they started out with what for
anyone else would have been a very nice
family nest egg to begin with but now
they've created generational wealth and
they're just going from there we'll see
how far they can go
[Music]